foreign
these families have nowhere to go their
possessions reduced to the items they
can carry
[Music]
thousands of people in Democratic
Republic of Congo have been forced to
leave their homes
it's now too dangerous to stay in their
Village as fighting between troops and
m-23 Rebels comes closer
the M23 Fighters were shooting bullets
all over our village in North kivu
Province that's why we had to flee we
had to in order to stay alive
for many a makeshift shelter is now home
and it's difficult to find food
foreign
stories of violence are shared every day
it was one o'clock in the morning when
we first heard gunshots we had to flee
because the situation became unbearable
the fighting has destabilized the
Central African country it has accused
its neighbor Rwanda of backing the
rebels to gain control of strategic
regions
the armed group is one of many in
eastern Dr Congo it's resurfaced and
sees more territory after years of being
torment forcing people out
we estimate that at least 40 000 people
are already displaced and that just
accounts for people coming from the town
of ruchuru right now we're in a camp not
far from Goma but as we speak people are
still arriving we see families on
motorbikes with their children with
their cattle and goats it's a very
difficult situation the government is no
longer just facing the threat of the
Armed group but with coping with entire
Villages of people who've lost
everything
Al Jazeera